[Music]
okay everybody i am so so excited today
because i am joined by shelly hennig aka
lisa mary holland aka sloan and
christina anthony aka detective lane in
the woman in the house across the street
from the girl in the window out on
netflix now we're talking spoilers so
make sure you watch the show first then
come back here how you guys doing today
great
yeah i mean this is the first time i've
done interview with three people at once
so i feel like it's like a party and
there wouldn't be three people would
rather have than you guys so i'm really
excited about this um
shelley with your first our wine
shelly too with your character of lisa i
i love how
crazy this character is but also the
twist we find out that she's actually
chastity um when you're finding your
portrayal of this character is this from
something external like another
character maybe from tv or film or is it
like internal like maybe a dark side of
shelley you're tapping into
it's definitely from all the reality
shows that i watch um like real
housewives
i love like the
the fighting with the smile
you know like and like the you know the
the facade that one maybe needs to have
in certain cities whether it be beverly
hills or
park city utah
um i yeah i've i've been leaning into
reality shows the last few years
um which has been fun so that a lot of
it came from that and also just
digging deeper
into like who this person is that she
has to be two different people why why
is she in this position why does she
want to
you know con men out of money um is it a
need is it a desire and i actually
played a little more into it being a
desire
as opposed to need i kind of wanted it
to like why do i need a reason
like i don't want people to necessarily
feel bad for chastity it's also not in
the script but you know as actors we
could kind of add that and i was like
you know what i think she just likes
like
the movies like casino and godfather and
she's just always wanted to be the
female version of
those people
and um
yeah
yeah no that would play different people
which i did not know was a thing until
after i got the part
yeah no i love that approach too and it
comes off great in the show now
mary you're kind of on the opposite end
here we were playing anna's best friend
one of my favorite running bits with
sloan is that she always just shows up
to anna like
without giving you know is i have a
feeling though is this kind of merry in
real life do you just show up are you
someone who
part of me is i really wish i i could do
that because i i love i love the idea of
just a pop buy
like a like just say oh just a casual
popeye i could never
i could never i'm way too um
way too
considerate london
well to consider it's a nice way to look
at it i i worry way too much about being
a burden on anybody or uh or being
annoying in any way so i would i would
never drop by unannounced but i love
playing the character that does because
it does feel like she has such a uh
familial relationship with anna that she
can just like she knows that
oh it's an open door policy between us
yeah
yeah and i think what's magical about
this whole meeting we're having right
now is that you were the first one to
show up and you popped up like that
after i just binged the show so i'm
still absolutely in my head
so i was like i thought that was pretty
ironic but yeah and that makes total
sense what you're saying mary and
christina now you're playing detective
lane here and what i love about your
scenes with kristen is they're so
serious but it's so silly what's
actually happening so
how do you guys not break or are you
guys breaking ever because i'm sitting
there watching how are one of them not
laughing right now
um i definitely broke but i will say to
my
in my defense i was the one breaking
during the table read when we all had to
like read the script together and i
definitely put myself on silence so they
knew that i had a problem
and yeah i yeah i just i was crying i
found everything so funny and yeah we
just would they would let me get my
giggles out and
kristen would tell them she needs
someone to pat her face dry there's
tears on her face
and then i just get back right back into
it but i was
sick
it's ridiculous what this woman is
saying if she came to my door
if this police officer came to your door
you should go investigate your own
murders
hell yeah
no and yeah
i think that's what's great though is
that character protective lane runs off
so well with kristen's character and
it's those scenes are great um now
shelley is it
just more fun at the other day for you
to play a meme character that says some
ruthless stuff here especially even
things like not liking markers because
they smell like is that always more fun
to play for you
um
yeah
yeah uh
you know i i think
being the nice girl was like
the last
you know previous to maybe three or four
years ago like previous to that was like
10 years of that's all i can speak for
in my career was just like the nice girl
like that's that's what i got to
uh play
so in the last few years it's definitely
um
gotten more interesting and more uh
yeah um so now i read scripts and
i get to be a [ __ ]
like it's great and not just like the
[ __ ] role like
they're
dense there's so much going on i'm
playing a con artist like that's cool
and usually there's it's not always that
like the female character is playing the
con artist definitely more now but um
yeah i'm just happy to be a part of that
new wave
no totally and it's great too because
it's so hard to pull off an antagonist
and you do a great job at it now mary i
absolutely one of my favorite
screenplays from last year was happiest
season and i know that you wrote on that
is if there's a season two for the show
would you be open to writing some
episodes for it because i'd love to see
you kind of again
i would be beyond honored but i feel
like
rachel and hugh and larry have such a uh
a unified
voice in this there there it's just uh
what they have created together is just
it's a real sculpture of a of a series
so
while i would love to insert myself in
there um
i feel like i feel like there's a very
perfect um balance between the three of
them that i don't want to mess up
well look you're definitely on deck and
maybe they'll get busy or something
though they're going to call you right
away
you have my number
look right into the lens
you have my number there you go
boom um okay christina i also want to
ask you too um are you approaching this
character detective lane as you would if
you were like playing a detective in
like an episode of csi like do you think
comedy or is it because it's such a you
know dry character how do you approach
it as an actor
um
i for this you know my bread and
butter's comedy and sketch and improv
but for this we
we did takes two different ways so there
were some takes where i was like the
crazy
are you crazy anna this is like a killer
this is a murder and then we did one
that was like really
the most
deadpanned subtle way you could do it
and they chose most of those takes
there's only one i thought it was a
little
crazy but um and it to me
it it really did work i i was really i
was pleasantly surprised but yeah i i
think
it was a real i think it just took us
all trusting each other and trusting
michael layman who's wonderful director
and kristin was there to also just kind
of guide the scenes and set the tone and
just to make sure you know we were all
playing in the same field but um yeah i
was really happy to be a comedian but
playing my position
which in this case was to play it pretty
straight
yeah and that's cool to hear that you
did other versions of the takes too and
you being someone who's been doing this
for a while too it's awesome it shows
how skilled you are too and
my last question i have to ask this
shelly a couple days ago you posted an
instagram that you had promoted the
wrong title of the show
what exactly happened there what did you
call the show because i couldn't find it
yeah what exactly happened i don't
remember what i called it
all ass backwards and wrong and you
called it gone girl right yeah
gone girl three i don't know
but it just i i'm dramatic i really
panicked and i really needed to
apologize and i hope i hope rachel you
and larry and kristen and michael layman
i hope everybody forgives me
well in your defense it's probably the
hardest title i have ever had to say in
an interview so props to you everybody
make sure to check out the woman in the
house across the street from the girl in
the window which is out now on netflix
obviously if you've already watched it
tell people to watch it re-watch it
watch these women absolutely crush it
here thank you guys so much for joining
me today i'll talk to you guys again in
the future
thank you thanks so
much you